welcome to episode 22 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr paul
saladino
paul's one of the leading authorities on
the carnivore diet
he's used this diet to reverse
autoimmunity chronic inflammation and
mental health issues in hundreds of
patients
many of whom have been told their
conditions were untreatable
he has a podcast focused on the diet
called fundamental health
and is the author of the book the
carnivore code
if you need an episode on the carnivore
diet to attempt to legitimize it
to your relatives or significant other
or anyone
this might be it i think the episode is
full of important information on the
science behind the diet
he and i do different opinion on a few
things one
he goes for a nose-to-tail approach to
the carnivore diet
which means eat most parts of the animal
i don't think people
need to eat nose to tail if they keep
their fat ratio fairly high
and considering there's limited evidence
about anything regarding the diet
i think that's reasonable i ate only
steak for the first year
of my diet and went into remission from
arthritis and
mood disorder without having to choke
down liver or something relatively
repulsive like spleen
i'm sorry nobody wants to eat a spleen
however
after about a year on the diet i did
include liver i probably now eat it
once a year and bone marrow which i do
love
now i do think if you're deficient in
certain vitamins then
organs are a fantastic way to get them
liver for instance
but i don't think it's necessary on the
diet for everyone other than the
differing opinion on whether or not
nose-to-tail carnivory is necessary on
this diet i think
paul's one of the most knowledgeable
doctors there is for the carnivore diet
and i would highly recommend reading his
book and following him on social media
if you want to learn more from a
physician who believes in the carnivore
diet
this episode is brought to you by true
local you may have heard me talk about
this company or post up stories on
instagram about them
but i'm excited because they're now a
podcast sponsor i've been using true
local for a couple of years and they're
my go-to source for meat at home
i buy meat from mennonites at a local
farmers market
and i get it shipped from true local and
that's how i get my meat in canada
what true local does is they partner
with local farmers and butchers in your
area to source high quality sustainable
meat
like 100 grass-fed and grass-finished
beef
lamb buffalo chicken tons of different
cuts that you might not be able to find
in your grocery store
you can build your own personalized box
that will give you the products you want
and it shows up at your door
it's cool that true local manages to get
people locally raised meat
but it's also a great way to support the
economy by shopping with smaller farms
butchers and suppliers
and an easy way to get sustainable meat
if you've been thinking about giving
them a shot or want a place that
sells excellent ribeyes even their
grass-fed ribeyes are good
and sometimes those can taste funny use
the code michaela
to get two free ribeyes with your order
their lamb is also the best lamb i've
ever had
so thank you true local for sponsoring
this episode and remember to use
the code michaela to get free steak with
your order
[Music]
dr paul saladino welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me on mikayla it's
good to be here
yeah i think the last time we talked i
was on your podcast
yeah that was when that was maybe a
little over a year ago i think
yeah it was before everything went
completely nuts
what happened what happened i have no
idea uh if you ask the astrologers
things just didn't line up well in the
universe
i'm at that point i'm not sure what
happened i think a comet
came by the earth and threw the
rotational axis off because
it just feels like some cosmic event has
been
massively something is massively
misaligned and
hopefully it will begin to be righted in
some universal way soon but my goodness
i don't know what happened yeah i don't
know what happened either
um so can you give my audience a bit of
an introduction to who you are and what
it is that you do
yeah so i'm basically a surfer
a guy that likes to be in the mountains
and in the wilderness who
ended up going to medical school twice
and just was
really curious about what causes disease
and prevents all of us humans from
living as well as we can
um you know life is really cool for a
lot of us and you know you've suffered
through a lot of things
um you know a lot of people listening to
this have had their own medical issues
and i think that as someone who got to
experience a lot of really beautiful
things in life a lot of wilderness
a lot of great skiing and mountaineering
and and ocean
experience and i just i was even more
motivated to understand
why some people don't get to do that or
why some people's bodies and health
or mental health just really don't work
well
so i'm kind of this i i think of myself
now is this intersection between
this vagabond surfer ski bum guy who
accidentally sort of went to medical
school and is really fascinated by
how to help people get back to living
lives that are full
of just super rich experiences by
getting their health back to what it
should be
so i can give a more detailed
explanation if you guys want the
technical details but that's the high
level
no no that that's good um i have a whole
bunch of questions to throw at you
we know you're one of the main carnivore
diets
uh doctors on the carnivore diet scene
so i thought and i haven't interviewed
anyone who was
kind of an expert in the carnivore diet
and i get questions obviously all the
time about
how the carnivore diet works whether or
not it's sustainable
you know cholesterol heart disease high
sodium levels
all these things people are terrified
about so i thought i could just throw a
whole bunch of questions at you so i can
direct people to this episode if they
have
questions that they want a doctor to
answer about the carnivore diet
i'm happy to it's it's been a really
fascinating
journey for me with a carnivore diet i
wrote a book about it the carnivore code
and
you know in my own medical wanderings
it's where i ended up
i got really fascinated by autoimmune
diseases like yours like your dads
like mine i had eczema uh you know i
know you guys had some variant of
arthritic conditions and or other
conditions and
it's fascinating to think about the way
that our diet really is
in my opinion the biggest lever in
health and disease so hit me with all
those questions yeah happy to answer
them
so first how long have you been on the
carnivore diet so right about
now i'm coming up it's right about two
years now and it's been
a nose-to-tail carnivore diet which we
can get into i eat the whole animal so
i'm interested in eating the organs
and as someone who's really focused on
nutritional biochemistry it's been
fascinating to think about
which pieces of the animal give us which
nutrients and then also from a
historical anthropological perspective
why our ancestors did this how they
might have benefited from eating
different parts of the animal
and how our ancestors were consuming
meat plants
there's a lot of sort of nuance about
this that i think gets lost and in
today's medical and health environment
i think we've got everything backwards
which is just another reason that
conversations around
carnivore diets and animal-based diets
which we might think of as a much
broader
term are so relevant because if you go
out on the street today
and i'm sure you could do this and even
in serbia and i can do this here in the
us
and you ask 10 or 100 people i think 90
to
95 or 98 are going to tell you that kale
is healthier than steak or kale is
healthier than liver
and i believe with every fiber of my
being that is completely wrong
and therein lies the problem is that so
much of what we've been told about
health
is wrong and is based on faulty studies
really misinterpreted epidemiology which
we can get into
and it's really leading people astray
and i think that as humans
we need to have the most nutrient rich
foods in our diet they have unique
you know value for us and if we are not
telling
our family our children our parents if
we are not learning for ourselves what
the foods are that make us whole
healthy humans how are we ever supposed
to get to a plant where we can live
fully and so
it's a very fascinating journey for me
too
yeah okay let's start with uh let's
start with some of the main concerns for
the carnivore diet starting with
how can you possibly not become nutrient
deficient
on a carnivore diet that's a great
question i think the real question is
how can you possibly not become
nutrient-deficient eating a lot of
plants
because if you look at there's a whole
chapter in my book about
where we get our nutrients from and by
nutrients let's just start with
high-level discussions of vitamins and
minerals
vitamins would be things like vitamin a
d e k
vitamin c minerals magnesium
selenium manganese copper zinc other
vitamins would be all the b vitamins
from thymine to b12
and if you really just look at
nutritional databases you can look at
the usda database i think they're in the
28th version right now
and there's a graphic of this in my book
which i can actually screen share if you
want
and you compare where we get these known
vitamins and minerals from
animal organs like liver are clearly the
super food and with animal meat being a
close second
so and if you compare that to any quote
superfood from plants it's just
abundantly obvious that
humans get their nutrients from animals
sure you can get a little bit of this
vitamin
or a little bit of this mineral from one
plant or another but
at an academic level to construct a diet
from exclusively plants and i know
that's not what we're suggesting
but to construct a diet from exclusively
plants and to imagine that you're going
to get
a full array a comprehensive array of
the vitamins and minerals that humans
need
is is just a fool's errand and i'm not
suggesting that anyone doing that is
foolish just that perhaps they're not
understanding where they get something
from
in their diet nutritionally at a science
level it's
if you look at both the nutritional
adequacy where the vitamins and minerals
live
in absolute amounts and the
bioavailability we see
marked differences between plants and
animal foods
so if we just talk about actual absolute
amounts of vitamins and minerals
for mostly everything you'll find it's
they're more prevalent in animal foods
i'm talking about retinoic acid the
biological equivalent of vitamin a
i'm talking about things like epa dha
zinc
copper selenium manganese b
vitamins they're just more prevalent
heme iron they're more prevalent in
animal foods
and then the other piece of the equation
that often gets left out is the
bioavailability of these
vitamins and minerals is much higher
from animal foods
and it makes sense because animals look
a lot more like humans evolutionarily
than a plant does
remember that a plant inhales carbon
dioxide and
exhales oxygen it's completely the
reverse of what humans do
and all of their biochemistry split from
ours
500 plus million years ago we're much
more
closely related at a biochemical level
to
ruminants like cows or deer or chicken
or pigs
than we are to a plant that uses
photosynthesis
to breathe in carbon dioxide to exhale
oxygen
and uses energy from the sun in a
chloroplast to make atp
we have completely different biological
systems plants have different versions
of
coding they have a different operating
system than humans which means a lot of
these nutrients look differently in
plants
or they're packaged in a way that humans
don't do a good job of extracting
so what am i talking about here let's
use vitamin a as an example
the plant form of vitamin a is
beta-carotene
and the animal form of vitamin a is
retinoic acid
now many will know that you can take an
enzyme in your body called bcmo
and cleave beta-carotene into two
molecules of retinoic acid
but that conversion doesn't happen as
efficiently as we would like
there are polymorphisms there are sort
of randomly occurring mutations quote
unquote
in enzymatic genes like bcmo in humans
which prevent many of us from doing that
efficiently even those of us that can do
it efficiently
the literature would suggest that we can
only really get
the biological equivalent of one unit of
retinoic acid
in 21 000 units of beta-carotene
so this means that if you're trying to
get the rda the recommended daily
allowance
of beta-carot of vitamin a of
biologically available retinoic acid
which is the form that humans use
from plant foods you would have to eat a
pound
a pound of sweet potatoes every day and
sweet potatoes are the most
readily available source of retin of
beta-carotene in plant foods
so and that doesn't even take into
account the fact that a lot of this
beta-carotene gets cleaved in a
different way
and there's a very interesting research
to suggest that different isomers of
beta-carotene cleavage
can block the retinoic acid receptor in
humans so what am i saying with all this
science jargon
it's very hard to get enough
biologically available
vitamin a from plants it's much easier
in animals
and there's a there are differential
cleavage products of beta-carotene that
can block
our retinoic acid receptors so just
using that one example
i would suggest that the majority of
humans are deficient in biologically
available
vitamin a that is retinoic acid and we
see this over
and over and over when you look at
multiple other vitamins whether it's
zinc
or iron look at females in this country
iron deficiency anemia
is very common this is primarily because
we're not getting enough heme iron
it's an iron molecule it's an iron atom
and it's encased in a porphyrin ring
well that's heme iron that's very
available to our body our gut sees that
and says aha come into this body i'm
ready for you
if our gut sees free iron or non-heme
iron from plants it's much harder to
absorb
so this is the the pattern we see over
and over
the the forms of these vitamins and
minerals
found in animals are much more
biologically
compatible with our human biology and
the forms and plants are foreign to us
we can sometimes get a little bit in
but it's very hard and then we have to
do all these fancy conversions and do
all this kind of like
break dancing jiu jitsu moves in our
biochemistry to make it work and it's
just kind of like
using honda parts in a tesla it doesn't
work so good you can limp around for a
little while but it's not going to be
ideal for humans
okay what about vitamin c great question
so this is really fascinating so there's
definitely vitamin c
in animal foods and we know this steak
liver all the organs spleen pancreas
things we don't think about eating but
are anti-scorpic meaning that they will
cure
scurvy so if we back up for a minute
people think of scurvy
as the main manifestation of vitamin c
deficiency and at some clinical level
it's the most
obvious now they were a really
fascinating set of experiments done in
the 1930s and 1940s
with conscientious objectors so this
could never have been done
now they were consciously subjected to
the war and they gave them
scurvy by depriving them of vitamin c
they gave them scurvy and then they
looked to see how much
vitamin c they had to replace in their
diet to correct scurvy at a clinical
level
it was 10 milligrams 10 milligrams of
vitamin c corrected scurvy clinically
and there was no clinical difference
between 10 milligrams
and 70 milligrams or even 150 milligrams
at a level of scurvy now people may know
that scurvy is a disease of
in improper formation of collagen
one of the things our body uses vitamin
c for is to add
a hydroxyl group to one of the strands
of a collagen molecule which is a
tri-helical molecule and if you don't
add a hydroxyl group
in a vitamin c dependent reaction the
collagen falls apart
so what people get when they get scurvy
they get bleeding gums you get petechiae
little red spots on your
on your skin because your blood vessels
are leaking because the collagen
is just falling apart now you have to
get less than 10
milligrams of vitamin c a day for that
to happen
you can get 10 milligrams of vitamin c
in
maybe seven to eight ounces of steak in
perhaps
less than one ounce of liver in you know
less than one ounce of brain we don't
eat it but our ancestors certainly did
so you can get vitamin c in lots of
animal foods
if provided that you don't make them
into spam or super heat them or process
them into oblivion right so
we're talking about fresh animal foods
that are not overcooked
now people will often ask a follow-up
question which is well
is there an optimal level of vitamin c
beyond the scurvy preventing level
and there probably is a little bit more
of that but it's not really well
established that excess
doses or these megadoses of vitamin c
that we see people taking today
are that helpful there's a really
interesting study that i mentioned in my
book
and this was a study in denmark where
they took i think it was around 60 or 80
people
and they took half the group and they
had them continue on their diet which
was pretty low in fruits and vegetables
maybe only like three servings per week
that group gets only
70 70 milligrams of vitamin c per day
they took another group and they had
that group increase the fruits and
vegetables
markedly like 10 to 15 servings of
fruits and vegetables per week sometimes
14 to 15 lots more vegetables and fruits
that group got 270 milligrams of vitamin
c per day
so 70 versus 270 milligrams of vitamin c
and at the end of the experiment they
saw vitamin c levels in the blood rise
35 in the group that got 270 milligrams
of vitamin c in their diet with more
fruits and vegetables
but when they looked at markers of
oxidative stress
inflammation and dna damage there was no
difference between them
so this study would at least suggest
that when we're talking about food
consumption of vitamin c
and you're increasing fruits and
vegetables and you're essentially almost
quadrupling 3.5 x
the amount of vitamin c fruits and
vegetables with a clear increase in
vitamin c levels in the serum
there's no change in the actual markers
we care about which are
oxidative stress markers right dna
damage things like this
so it's really fascinating to say okay
this group did just as well with 70
milligrams
of vitamin c as this other group did
with 270
and 70 milligrams of vitamin c is
something that most of us could get if
we are eating
a carnivore diet nose to tail now one of
the points that i'm careful to make as
i'm talking
with people these days is i think that
there are some people
like you and like me who feel better
with completely animal-based diets
but for most people what i'm most
excited about is helping them understand
which foods are the most beneficial for
them and which foods are probably
causing them harm
helping them understand that meat and
organs are the foods that are integral
to optimal human health and they've been
incorrectly vilified
and then helping them understand that
plants exist on a toxicity spectrum and
are not entirely benevolent
and that some plants have lots of toxins
that are causing a lot of problems for
people
whether it's skin issues or gi issues
etc so i like to kind of widen it to
people to help them understand there is
another option like a carnivore-ish diet
in which you eat animal meat and organs
and the least toxic plants and we can
talk about what those are later in the
podcast
but if you're doing something like that
it's also completely easy to use
half of a lime if you tolerate it to get
way over 70 milligrams of vitamin c in
your diet per day
but just the way that i construct my
diet eating animal meat animal organs
including thymus and liver and spleen on
a daily basis
i'm definitely getting 70 ish milligrams
of vitamin c per day
and i don't have scurvy you know and
when i do my blood markers as
you know as a as a you know as a as a
physician as a scientist interested in
this i do my own blood markers
there's no evidence of increased
oxidative stress or lipid peroxides or
dna damage so
does that make sense with vitamin c
that's a that's a really important
question
yeah well that's one of the main
questions people ask and that was a lot
of the
a lot of the negative articles that were
written about the diet in like 2018 were
oh well don't worry
they'll die of scurvy or something so
don't don't worry about it
um i actually i didn't do nose to tail i
did
um i just did steak for the first year
and i still had
no problems and that was high fat steak
right i wasn't just eating sirloin or
something i was eating ribeye
and ribs and i had no problem and then
i kind of automatically i hated liver
i hated liver with a fiery passion
forever
and then after a year of only eating
steak i had liver cravings
and then liver tasted sweet and i was
like i thought this taste i thought this
was terrible
before um and it tasted good and so i
had quite a bit of liver for about three
months in the winter
maybe that had something to do with
vitamin d i have no idea
and then it started tasting not so great
again so i stopped eating it again
so i seem to have liver cravings once a
year other than that i do
steak and ribs and i probably get more
collagen because i'm
i do a lot of ribs um but i've been
totally fine for vitamin c and
all my vitamin deficiencies went away i
this terrible zinc deficiency
since i was like seven it finally
righted itself after
eight months on the carnivore diet yeah
and i think that the zinc deficiency is
a great illustrator here
there's a part in the book where i talk
about this a lot of the compounds found
in plants prevent us from absorbing
minerals
so there's a great experiment that has
been done with oysters which are one of
the most
biologically dense sources of zinc
and you can give someone oysters and see
blood levels of zinc rise
really strikingly after a meal and then
you can give them oysters with
beans or beans and tortillas and you can
completely blunt
the rise in zinc levels in the blood so
not only are
i think people not taking in enough
bioavailable zinc in animal foods
liver meat spleen things like this
they're also eating it with foods that
we've been told are healthy
like whole grain tortillas or beans
and they're not absorbing it because
oxalates and phytic acid are molecules
that
wrap around the zinc they chelate it and
they pull it out of the body
so it's really interesting to think
about the other thing that
i'm curious about is um for a lot of
people that don't like the organs or
can't eat them
that's i think why the desiccated organ
supplements are so valuable and serve a
role like
you know my sister has kids and i think
here you go they can like she like opens
our supplements from heart and soil just
into the the apple sauce for her kids or
or avocado and then you can get you know
a two-year-old to eat liver
if they need more of those nutrients in
a way that's so much more easy to do
that's true i'm still i don't know i
think the the one
area when where we may have
disagreements is
i i the only way i managed to heal was
to exactly listen to what i wanted to
eat
once i got rid of all the extremely
addictive things i was eating like
you can't listen to your body if you're
consuming like high fructose corn syrup
because then it just tells you to eat
more of that but once i cut all that out
i've managed to do the carnivore diet
just by
cravings and at some point i'll crave
like i said fattier cuts or leaner
cuts or sometimes liver bone marrow i
love
um but i haven't needed to eat anything
i didn't want to eat i've managed to do
it
man i tried raw brain once which was
horrifying see i
love robert i love for offering it was
horrible like i remember
i i don't eat oysters like um just
because
i can't really manage anything other
than the ruminant meat
wild salmon actually seems to be okay
now that i've been doing it for a while
but i used to hate oysters anyway raw
brain
tasted like oysters except there was no
sauce on it
it was terrible that was my experience
with a very small piece of raw brain
yeah well it's interesting for me to
hear that you sometimes get cravings for
liver and i
i think that this is just my sense but i
think that as humans it's hard for us to
crave something we haven't eaten before
so it's good that you've eaten bone
marrow and liver
that's one of the desiccated organ
supplements we make at heart and soil
and you can crave that when your body
needs it perhaps but
a lot of people have never eaten spleen
or brain i guess you're never going to
crave brain but
you know we've never eaten a pancreas so
we're not like you know what i want to
eat some pancreas
so it's just it's hard for people to get
to understand like
i think that every once in a while i'll
get a craving for tripe or intestine i'm
like you know oh god i've had tripe too
i can't do tribe i i see your point and
that is a good point
how do you crave something you've never
had if it's something our ancestors made
i'm not sure if i i don't know how i
feel about the whole
pancreas eating thing but i do
see that point and i certainly do have
periods where i crave liver but
generally
when i talk to people i say just you
know don't don't just eat lean meat
because that doesn't make people feel
good no no no
but your body seems to kind of figure it
out
after all most people do um although
interestingly enough um speaking of
liver specifically is i've always had
low vitamin d
and i've had a hell of a time it's
actually just above baseline now for the
first time ever but i had shots and
things was kind of cheating
but i had a hell of a time getting the
vitamin d up even though i was spending
time in the sun
um and i tried eating liver to
correct that but i think that has
something to do with the autoimmune
problem i have with vitamin d
specifically
but it could that was the only vitamin i
had issues with
getting back up you're not going to like
this
but blood is yeah it's a good source of
vitamin d
so you think if you eat rarer meat yeah
is it higher in vitamin d
or if you can actually get blood our
ancestors may have had that in the
winter
you know like never drinking blood and
you can put well maybe we'll get you
some of our
so we make a blood builder i make it we
make a capsule with like desiccated
blood in it
and it has that has vitamin d but it's
mostly sun for people but you're right
in inflammatory conditions
you can get um you can get vitamin d
going down but if your calcium is good
and you feel good
and your bone density is good i think
there's a lot of variability in terms of
what vitamin d is optimal
i see a lot of people saying oh you need
to have your vitamin d above 40
or above 50 or above 60 and i think
that's not really true for humans
i think that for most people with the
coronavirus data we clearly saw the
cutoff was 30
and if your vitamin d was above 30 there
was a real difference in your outcome
like a striking difference
so i think that if most people are
getting in the sun and i think real
sunlight is different than a pill
which is fascinating when it comes to
vitamin d because there are other things
made in the sun in the skin and you know
this being on the beach it feels good to
humans
this is kind of our ancestral blueprint
right there are other things
made in our skin in the sun beyond
vitamin d that are helpful for us
we make nitric oxide in the sun in our
skin and that's something that helps
vasodilate our blood vessels
we make endorphins which is probably why
vitamin the sunlight feels good
we make something called cholesterol
sulfate who knows we don't even know
what that does in humans
it's a water-soluble adduct of
cholesterol so being in the sun is
really the way to do it
for humans vitamin d supplements if you
can't but there's like all these
biological nuances and we kind of hinted
at this earlier
there are many nutrients and things that
are nutritive for humans
that we don't even really know about
right now which is another reason that
eating nose and tail is interesting for
me
there's all these peptides which are
cool too these signaling molecules that
do good things in the human body
like bpc157 that occurs naturally
in the stomach you know so you can get
bpc157 when you eat
the stomach of an animal or thymus and
alpha 1
is in the thymus or in the liver there's
all these microbial peptides
there was a really cool series of
experiments done in the 1970s it's like
ancient history
but they took raw or desiccated liver
and they gave it to
mice and the mice just go crazy they
feel so they're like so energetic and
they run around
and they compare it to cooked liver and
it's different there's like some
compound
independent of the vitamins and minerals
in liver that helps the same has been
seen with spleen they can give the
extracts
like desiccated extracts of these organs
to animals and they get really
excited and healthy so if anyone has a
dog they know this if you try and offer
your dog any of these things they go
absolutely crazy for them
okay you said raw liver though right raw
or desiccated
raw or desiccated okay one of the
problems i think people have
coming into the diet other than the fact
that it sounds insane
it does and they don't know what to do
right like i say
have beef salt and water and they're
like well what about the vegetables you
know or how much salt do i eat how much
beef do i eat like what do i eat how do
i cook meat
um i'm concerned that telling people
that they also have to
eat things like desiccated or raw liver
turns off people who already have
like boundaries up against trying the
carnivore diet
possibly i mean i guess that's why you
put it in the capsule and it's like just
take this capsule of desiccated liver
that's easier than eating raw liver
although i'll tell you the friends of
mine that i've been able to convince to
try raw liver shooters or like that is
definitely the way to do it it's a
hundred percent
you know i i watched your i watched your
instagram videos too many times and
you'd convinced all these people to try
frozen liver or raw liver or whatever
i tried just a tiny piece no it's like
slimy and
like oyster-like i'm really not a fan of
the slime
and so but basically just people know
what we're describing i don't i don't
always chew the raw liver i'll put it in
my mouth
and then i'll take a swig of toppo chico
i know you love pellegrino
and i'll just swallow it whole so you
get a little bit of like the irony taste
which is probably something that it
takes a while for humans to get adapted
to but you're right
i think that ultimately i just want
people to feel better and if it's a
burden don't let that be the burden
which is why
i hope that capsules will help people
get through that if they're looking for
that type of nutrition
because i think it is interesting with
like peptides and the nutrients and
stuff but i love your idea
of a lion diet of a super simplified
carnivore diet people think of a
carnivore diet in general
as an autoimmune diet and i think wait a
minute actually
no if you have really severe autoimmune
issues i think you should go simpler to
like a lion diet or
a nose to tail line diet which we can
coin on this podcast where you basically
eat beef
organs bone broth and salt and and you
don't have milk you don't have
chicken you don't have pork you
definitely don't have dairy and then go
from there
and i've seen a lot of people do better
when they cut out chicken
when they cut out pork when they cut out
eggs and when they cut out milk
and those are i think less offensive
than like kale or broccoli
those are not foods that humans should
be eating in any amount if we want to
thrive but
still the way that a lot of these foods
are raised specifically chicken and eggs
are fed a lot of corn and soy
a lot of pork is fed corn and soy
they're not species-appropriate diets
and you know a lot of milk i just think
a lot of people myself included
have a lot of intolerance to casein and
whey
no matter what i do with dairy i get x
amount of flaring and i think that's not
what i want i don't want my immune
system to be pissed off it's a very
clear indication
of that and i just think evolutionarily
it makes sense we would not have had
a lot of dairy we also would not have
had a lot of eggs i'm not saying
and everybody needs to cut out eggs just
saying if people are not thriving
there's a potential that the albumen and
the egg white could be triggering it
eggs are a seasonal food too and most
chickens are not fed species appropriate
diets
yeah yeah for sure when i first started
cutting out foods in 2015
and went down to a super limited diet
dairy and eggs were one of the top
foods that uh gave me this terrible
autoimmune problems
so it was soy grains it was legumes and
completely not just soy so it was just
the worst spawn of the devil
yeah holy i hallucinated when i
tried to reintroduce that
yeah it was horrible but um anyway
dairy and eggs were up there egg whites
i really couldn't tolerate so yeah if
you're
trying the carnivore diet and you're
still having issues you could simplify
it and then try and reintroduce
later just to make sure those aren't
bothering you people email me all the
time and they say
i'm doing a carnivore diet and not doing
good what's wrong and i say well tell me
about your diet and
yeah a lot of the time they get yeah
cheese or bacon
which is really high in linoleic acid
and they they're
do or has corn and soy and stuff and so
or dairy
or they're not getting bone broth or you
know or something i'm like
try this and often it is really helpful
i didn't do bone broth for the first
year either do you like it now
yeah but i had to figure out how to cook
it so i was slow cooking it just if
anyone wants to know how to cook it you
get a pressure cooker
and just cook a bunch of bones you can
roast them first and then cook them if
you want
but if you get a pressure cooker makes a
huge difference slow cooker they can
taste like aged and mushroomy
and so all my broth was aged and
mushroomy i think i would have liked it
at the beginning if i'd known how to
cook it and
you need a pressure cooker i have an
instant pot it's so easy i have an
instant pot too i get patella
bones which have tendons on them if
people have not tried tendons in a
pressure cooker they're delicious like
they're so good and your hair i don't
know what you've noticed but like my
nails grow super fast
and i mean people always say collagen
for hair skin and nails and it's not
it's the truth like if you start eating
bone broth
i don't know did you notice any changes
in your hair your skin or your nails
when you added it in
um my skin and my hair and my nails has
drastically improved on the
on the carnivore diet i probably didn't
add bone broth in until about a year
into the diet
um i don't know i just kind of kept
getting better i didn't notice a massive
improvement when i started eating more
bone broth
but the only reason i started eating it
really was because
i wanted some variation and i've got an
instant pot which i highly recommend
because
bone broth is actually good i was also
so used to eating it with vegetables and
i was used to chicken bone broth too so
i didn't like beef bone broth and then i
stopped eating chicken
it was rough it took me a year but i
figured it out beef burn broth for
tendons is amazing
yeah i i actually would recommend that
that it is good
uh okay okay next question that people
ask all the time
what about high cholesterol doesn't this
cause high cholesterol and isn't going
to cause heart disease
sure so this is a really interesting
question and
this is hotly debated and i am squarely
in the camp
of physicians and thinkers who do not
believe that a high
ldl so low density lipoprotein
which is colloquially known as
cholesterol
is is the de novo cause of
atherosclerosis and i'll tell you what
people mean by that
so if you look at the literature there's
a whole chapter in my book about this
it's a little bit it's a little bit hard
to sort out but
what what i think is pretty apparent is
that to say that ldl
causes heart disease is an incorrect
statement we cannot prove that
in some epidemiologic cohorts in some
observational cohorts
we do observe that a higher ldl
cholesterol
is associated with a higher incidence of
coronary artery disease
but remember this is observational
research and one of the most
interesting subgroup analyses that i've
seen is of the framingham study
and this is in my book as well so if you
take a graph of this framingham study
which is an epidemiology study done in
framingham massachusetts
and you graph ldl cholesterol
over cardiovascular disease incidents
the ldls on the x-axis cardiovascular
disease relative risk is on the y-axis
and i can actually show a graph of this
if you want to do a screen share and you
don't stratify you just look at the
whole cohort there is a relationship
the higher your ldl the more likely the
risk of cardiovascular disease again
this is a correlation
it helps us generate a hypothesis but we
cannot draw a causative
inference so the hypothesis would be ldl
cholesterol causes heart disease
well that hypothesis starts to break
down when you look at the data further
so one of there's some very smart
researchers that took that exact same
data
and they stratified people into groups
by their hdl
so people will think of ldl as bad
cholesterol quote unquote which i don't
believe it's bad at all and i'll tell
you why
and hdl cholesterol as good cholesterol
so if you stratify people by group
into and you look at the ldl
by hdl in relationship to cardiovascular
disease incidents
you'll now take one line and split it
into four lines
does that make sense so you have one
line is an hdl of 85 one line is an hdl
of 65 one line is an hdl of 45
and one line is an hdl of 25 and in all
of those hdl subgroups you can look for
the relationship between
ldl and cardiovascular disease and the
findings are
striking once you get to an hdl of 65 or
the association between ldl cholesterol
and cardiovascular disease essentially
evaporates
there is no longer a strong relationship
between ldl and cardiovascular disease
well how can that be if ldl causes
heart disease you should see exactly the
same relationship in all of those
clearly there's at least one more
variable here but what is hdl telling us
hdl is a really really good surrogate
for metabolic
dysfunction or metabolic health
colloquially this is known as insulin
resistance though that's a very
misleading term
but what hdl is telling us is that in
those people
who are more metabolically broken and
have a lower hdl
there sure is a relationship between ldl
and cardiovascular disease
but if you are metabolically healthy
that is insulin sensitive
and you have an hdl that is high those
two correlate very strongly
there is essentially no relationship
between ldl cholesterol
and cardiovascular disease so the
equation is much more complex than
people would have us believe
and when you start to think about it
evolutionarily it makes a lot of sense
so i'll just throw out some things that
people probably have never heard
when we fast i know you're a huge fan of
fasting
there's great evidence that when you or
i fast our ldl goes
up our ldl goes up when we fast
why would why would why would fasting be
killing us
so michaela are you causing heart
disease by fasting no
it's something that evolutionary would
have done all the time ldl goes up
because it's one of the ways
our body moves nutrients around the body
ldl low density lipoprotein doesn't just
exist to kill us in fact it's not
killing us at all in my opinion
it moves cholesterol and triglycerides
it's like a it's like a bus
and it's full of cholesterol and
triglyceride passengers
and it moves that cholesterol around the
body to make hormones
estrogen testosterone these hormones are
made of cholesterol
if you don't want any cholesterol in
your body you can get your ldl very low
there's a genetic condition called smith
lemly opped syndrome in which this
occurs
unfortunately most of these kids die in
utero and those that are born and live
have severe mental retardation
massive problems with infections and
many other things most of them don't
make it past their third or fourth
birthday
because their cholesterol is so low they
have a defect
in the enzymatic pathway that makes
cholesterol now remember that
cholesterol is packaged into ldl
these kids have very very low ldl and
the way we treat them
is we give them lots of egg yolks we
give them bucket loads
of cholesterol and egg yolks to try and
bypass
this problem so if you don't make
cholesterol
you can get your ldl very very low but
you will also see
many other problems in the human body so
ldl is also involved in the immune
response
and this came out with the coronavirus
pandemic people with lower ldls had
worse outcomes
and so you can understand that ldl the
ldl molecule is a bus
but it moves these molecules around our
body and it also can
prevent the invaders whether it's a
virus or a bacteria
from sending their signals to other
organisms
so whether it's a gram-positive or
gram-negative organism these are
bacteria
they send out signals to each other and
ldl and hdl are involved in preventing
that crosstalk they interrupt the supply
chain
wow that's cool so ldl and hdl are
immunologic molecules in the human body
and there's lots of agree admittedly
it's observational there's lots of
observational research
to suggest that those with higher levels
of ldl
live longer in elderly populations
there's a study called the leiden 85
plus
study and people who had the highest ldl
live the longest
once you get to elderly age showing that
it's kind of
sorting out all the people who have
diabetes so if you have a high ldl
genetically or you are metabolically
healthy
and you have a high ldl it looks to be
protective
if you look at admissions to hospitals
for sepsis or infectious conditions
there's a real correlation with lower
ldl so it's really interesting there's
really good evidence that
ldl is an immunologic molecule in the
human body we probably want
more of it as long as we are
metabolically healthy
and there's so many things that point to
this direction so why would something
that is helping us immunologically that
is moving building blocks of cells
hormonal precursors around the body be
killing us at the same time
we're fasting it's going up you eat a
low carb diet it goes up
interesting do you want to know what my
ldl is yeah what is your ldl
i just had it tested it's 533
mine didn't go up at all i know it's
like it didn't change at all i had my
blood done it was like not
like it's in the well whatever the
theoretical
healthy range is it just didn't change a
bit
that was like a year and a half ago
right have you had it tested recently
yeah i got it test
that one i got it tested maybe two i got
it tested through rob wolf and he did
really in-depth testing and it was
everything was completely normal uh and
then i had it tested again and it's
yeah it's still the same and i just like
survive off of
fat like that's there's some there's
something genetic going on here i think
for some people they respond to this
with high ldl
but this is not the same high ldl that
occurs in diabetes
so this is the problem is that in
medicine when people have metabolic
dyslipidemia
or metabolic dysfunction that is
pre-diabetes the ldl rises a little bit
but an ldl that rises in me who's eating
a lot of saturated fat
and very little vegetable oil it's not
the same situation but in medicine we
can't see that we conflate the two
yeah and therein lies the problem so
when i saw that ldl my first ldl a
couple years ago
like a year into the carnivore diet was
300 something i thought wow that's
really high
i got my last one back i was like holy
moly 533
so i'm 43 years old my father
had a heart attack when he was 43. he's
a physician
and i have a primary relative with early
heart disease so i thought you know what
i'm going to get a coronary artery
calcium score and
scan yeah i don't i don't believe it's
going to show anything
my cac score is zero and so i've
i've had so interesting i've had an ldl
above 300
for over two years really almost three
years because my ldl was a little bit
high before
carnivore though i don't have familial
hypercholesterolemia
so i've had an ldl 300 to 500 for two
years
and i have zero plaque in my arteries
critics will say it's not long enough or
it's n
equals one yeah well it's a really
interesting n equals one
and the more people i talk to about this
have told me the same thing i have a
physician friend here in austin who said
yeah paul i've had an ldl above 300 for
10 years
and my cac is still zero and so then the
critics come back and they say well it's
not a good test well it's a pretty darn
good test if you have calcification
of plaque in your artery it will see it
humans can have non-calcified plaque but
i'll just keep doing it every year and
proving people wrong
and eventually people will say oh it's
an n of one but
i think it's a really interesting thing
and my results i think argue in the same
vein that
hey look i'm not getting xanthomas which
are on tendon sheaths you get these
deposits
of fatty deposits i'm not getting
xanthelasma
on my eyes you know i have an ldl that's
way higher than most people with
familial hypercholesterolemia
there's more there's more going on here
and the framingham study really
illustrates that
if you stratify most of the data sets
we're looking at epidemiology here
by metabolic dysfunction by metabolic
health
insulin sensitivity in a broad sense
you'll see completely different data
come out
you have to do that but people are
making the mistake they're looking at
all the data
broadly and they're saying yeah look
there's a correlation between ldl and
heart disease
but what do we know about our population
most of them are pretty damn sick so of
course there's going to be a correlation
but in those of us who are metabolically
healthy and we can talk about what i
think
is involved in that there doesn't seem
to be the same correlation it's
different and ldl has these beneficial
roles so
i'm excited about my ldl of 533 it means
i'm probably
moving a bunch of hormonal precursors
around making a ton of testosterone
and i'm very immunologically ready to uh
prevent any invaders from coming into my
body
hmm okay yeah well that makes sense to
me i was surprised mine hadn't changed
to be honest nothing really changed my
vitamins i was low in all my b vitamins
and zinc and vitamin d
and everything reddit itself except
vitamin d although like i said it's
above baseline now
thank goodness um have you tried
reintroducing any plant foods since you
went to the carnivore diet
i have yeah so i did an experiment
like uh earlier earlier this year where
i wore a continuous glucose monitor from
nutrisense
and it was fascinating because i so for
the first year and a half i did a
carnivore diet it was all meat and
organs there were no carbs
and it worked pretty good my athletic
performance was good but eventually i
would get like muscle cramps and i
started thinking about the signaling
roles of insulin and electrolytes in the
human body
and i thought okay i want to reintroduce
some carbohydrates and just see how i
feel
am i going to feel am i going to feel
warmer am i going to have less cramps am
i going to am i going to feel or am i
going to feel horrible
so i put on a continuous glucose monitor
and i introduced honey
on one day and then i introduced berries
and i did squash and i think i did sweet
potato
and those were the main things i did for
that two-week period
and you can see my blood glucose
response wasn't crazy
the honey spikes it a little bit it
doesn't go too high and then it comes
right back down the baseline which is
really interesting so
that suggests good insulin sensitivity
if you're looking at a continuous
glucose monitor
what you want to see is the area under
the curve of the glucose spike
not the absolute apex of glucose but the
area under the curve
what i found when i ate a lot of fruit
was that my stomach didn't feel great
like there was definitely a threshold
in terms of fruit consumption and i knew
this from my pre-carnivore days
if i ate like a pound of cherries
eventually i would just like start
farting and have to poop you know it was
just not a good thing
there's a limit on how many cherries i
can get before i get cherry belly
and the same happened with like
raspberries and fruit there was only so
much fruit i could eat before my stomach
got kind of gurgly
and when i started eating foods with
more fiber like squash or sweet potato
my stomach just felt distended it didn't
feel bloated but it felt really
distended
and i was like i don't like that super
full stretched feeling in my stomach i
don't like the way this fiber
feels people will know and we can talk
about pooping that
you don't need fiber to poop um
certainly if you put fiber in your diet
you're going to poop more
but i've never had a problem with
constipation throughout my carnivore
diet experience
so that's definitely not a carnivore
diet problem no
it's sometimes people get it and i think
it's because they're not eating enough
fat
it could be dairy or they're not eating
enough fat or they're not eating
collagen in some source yeah
we can talk about those hiccups if
people want to hear about it but
what i actually found was that after a
week or two of squash
the eczema started to come back on my
back and i thought that's interesting
like
i showed my friend in the gym i was like
look at this my accent was coming back
he was like whoa
just the squash and i thought all right
i don't need it in my diet i didn't
necessarily like the way it made my
stomach feel
but what i did like and people will be
surprised at this was i liked the way
that honey felt it didn't it didn't make
me feel bloated
it didn't make my stomach feel distended
and if i watched on the continuous
glucose monitor
my my blood glucose would go up and then
come right back down
and my baseline would stay very steady
my fasting blood glucose would stay very
low
and recent blood work has suggested that
my fasting insulin remains very low so
occasionally i will include some raw
organic honey
as a change of pace and it seems to work
pretty well with my body i've worn a lot
of continuous glucose monitors
to check this out people get really
worried about sugar or fructose
but there's some fascinating data
especially even with like dental stuff
so i interviewed
al danenberg who's a periodontist on my
podcast and he showed me a bunch of
literature
in in like in many countries they use
honey as an antibacterial in the mouth
they've used it to treat mucositis
gingivitis anti-plaque so
there's there's things in honey that if
you can tolerate them
appear to be beneficial for humans it's
a really interesting
compound and it's i would say i always
joke now if vegans won't eat it then
maybe i can eat it so maybe it's still
carnivore
because it's like it's sort of an animal
product right
did um if you have honey and you're in
ketosis how long does it take you to
drop back into ketosis once you eat it
uh probably a couple hours
depending how much yeah so i'll just
mention this
yeah while i believe ketosis is valuable
for humans
i've i've kind of expanded my
perspective here and come
to think that for a lot of us it's good
to cycle in and out
for a lot of reasons that to go out of
ketosis occasionally is probably
beneficial for humans and evolutionarily
consistent and
from an electrolyte maintenance
perspective i do think it's useful to
have some
insulin signaling from time to time at a
level above what you'll get at just
meat and fat now if you're eating
protein you will get insulin signaling
but if you add carbohydrates you'll get
more of that
insulin gets incorrectly vilified as
this bad molecule it's it's a good
molecule in the human body
it becomes a problem when the whole
system of energy balance gets thrown off
but in and of itself insulin is not
harmful to humans we need it to live
just like ldl is not harmful to humans
so many of these molecules get
incorrectly vilified without
proper understanding of like human
physiology so yeah it depends how much
honey i eat but if i eat
a couple of tablespoons i'll be back in
ketosis in a few hours definitely back
overnight
i do time-restricted feeding most days
where i'll eat breakfast and a
early dinner at like three o'clock and
then the next morning i check my ketones
they're almost always point five
millimolar
but i also don't chase ketones you know
if i'm in ketosis great if i'm not great
i think it's okay to be back and forth
and what i've seen and this is really
interesting so i did a podcast
uh with the folks from nutrisense
talking about cgms
and what they showed me data because
they have all this data from thousands
of people that have worn cgms
and there was somebody who had been keto
zero carb keto
for five years and you could see their
their baseline blood sugar was 120 to
all day so it's very high if you look at
the area under the curve they're going
to have a very high auc for glucose
where
as i get a spike from 80 to 120 and it
comes back to 75 within an hour my auc
is very small
and somebody that has a baseline glucose
of 120 to 125
is gonna have a hemoglobin a1c above six
even though they're never eating
carbohydrates you could have a
hemoglobin a1c
reflecting a 90-day average of your
blood sugar six plus
and it's it's probably it's an indicator
of glycation so is that is that normal
human physiology
i think that at that point we've become
too too
stuck on the low carb side yeah yeah um
that's
that's really interesting i've had so i
feel from my various experience
experiments
i feel better in a higher level of
ketosis
i definitely do um mentally mental
stability
energy i definitely feel better and
however i also like to eat jerky and if
you eat jerky
if i eat jerky i'm not in ketosis
anymore right even if i have a couple of
pieces then
i'll pop out of ketosis and it
definitely makes me feel
slower but it doesn't but that's it and
then i
go back into ketosis i i was in ketosis
for
when i first started the diet about six
months in
i was more heavily in ketosis and i
stayed in ketosis for
almost a year and a half without popping
out of it because i like the feeling
my blood glucose is always and i know
this is an n equals one and i
i don't understand what's going on with
those people that have super high blood
sugar because mine was
always under 80. but it's like there
must be something else going on
because how does that work and why
wouldn't that have happened to me
it happens over time so i see this in a
lot of people i work with
that there's a creep there's a creep in
the fasting blood glucose the longer you
stay
low carb and it's normal physiologic
insulin resistance
so here we get into a little bit of a
quagmire in terms of terminology and
actual physiology at the level of the
muscles
so if we don't eat carbohydrates if you
are in ketosis you are
technically insulin resistant at the
level of the muscles
your muscles are refusing glucose to
spare it for the brain
the ovaries the testicles the red blood
cells the kidneys
your muscles and a lot of other cells in
your bodies will put up a block to say
we don't want glucose we can run on
ketones
so there is something called physiologic
insulin resistance we need to have
different terminology for this because
the insulin resistance of metabolic
dysfunction also known as diabetes or
pre-diabetes
is a very different state than
physiologic insulin resistance
but you do see this and i see it in my
clients there's a creep
a steady creep up in fasting glucose if
you keep
avoiding carbohydrates strictly and i
see this in my clients they have a
fasting glucose of 106
108 110 115 and i think it happens over
five years for this person they get up
to 126 i mean
i don't know i don't know i've been
doing this for like three years in
october and my blood
glucose is low is it possible and i am
not
as well-versed scientifically as you not
even close
does it have anything to do does it have
anything to do with exercise
i mean i do a lot of intense exercise
too definitely you will see
exercise push it up i mean if you're
wearing a continuous glucose monitor
you'll see it push it up acutely but in
most people even if they if you go in a
sauna or a cold bath that'll also spike
your glucose
from baseline but for someone to have a
baseline glucose of 120 to 126
we just don't know and you see this
physiology in people who are keto for
long amounts of time
and it's very interesting now it may be
individual but it is a lot of area under
the curve for glucose
and you see that hemoglobin a1c go up
and you see
you see more glycation so is that is
that ideal human physiology
i'm not sure it is if you add
carbohydrates and occasionally
you will remind your muscles oh here's a
carbohydrate you should take this in
sometimes
and you can actually lower the fasting
blood glucose but ultimately it's just
about people doing what makes them feel
the best
we're still learning this is what's
crazy yeah none of this was taught to me
in medical school
you know if people have any i any notion
that i learned
any of this in medical school i want to
dispel them of that so
there are really no experts in in this
field we're all learning
we're all just trying to read science
and understand it and share our personal
experiences
i don't even think i was told about
ketosis as a state in medical school
other than starvation ketosis
the fact that people are doing the fact
that people are doing nutritional
ketosis dietary ketosis is
we're way outside of anything that's
studied in the medical literature and
thankfully there's people like
you know there's plenty of groups out
there that are looking at ketogenic
diets long term and they appear to be
very safe
i just think that there are some
drawbacks to them for a lot of people
and we should not fear carbohydrates in
most cases because
you know one of the things i've been
thinking about a lot recently is there
is a lot of carbohydrate
fear within ketogenic and carnivore
circles and i don't want people to get
too dogmatic because
all the research that i've done really
looks to point to the idea that
carbohydrates do not cause
diabetes de novo in an otherwise
metabolically healthy person
carbohydrates don't cause metabolic
dysfunction
it's something else i really think it's
linoleic acid and we can talk about why
that is and what's going on there
but there are many free living
populations on the planet
the katahvins the taverns the kids the
tucacenta who have large amounts of
carbohydrates in their diet
and don't have high they don't have
insulin resistance they don't have
metabolic dysfunction
now the nuance here is that for people i
don't think you fell into this category
with your autoimmune disease but for
people with
metabolic dysfunction that is diabetes
and pre-diabetes
or pre-pre-diabetes states removal of
carbohydrates can be very helpful
because you have i don't know i never
tested my blood glucose when i was like
21 and mostly dead and i was overweight
and things and i couldn't think like i'm
sure
my blood sugar was weirdly high i'm
sorry you know maybe
yeah you may have had i mean it's an and
often metabolic dysfunction
is connected with autoimmunity our
immune cells have insulin receptors and
we know that insulin resistance is
connected with
some degree now this is pathologic
insulin resistance metabolic dysfunction
is connected with some degree of
disordering uh disordered immune system
response we saw that with covid very
clearly
the people who had metabolic dysfunction
were much more likely to have severe
outcomes
because their immune system is
negatively affected the balance between
neutrophils and lymphocytes is all off
because of the sort of
the way that the insulin is tonic for
the immune system
but in a lot of people who have
metabolic dysfunction
removal of carbohydrates is critical in
the first step and is very helpful
because there is carbohydrate
intolerance but we should be careful not
to conflate this with the notion that it
caused the problem de novo
uh that is from nothing just like ldl
just like ldl doesn't cause
atherosclerosis
like carbohydrates don't cause diabetes
if you have diabetes
carbohydrates can make it worse unless
you eat nothing but carbohydrates
this is kind of a nuanced perspective
but if you are eating a mixed diet
carbohydrates will make your diabetes
worse and removing them
can be very helpful but that didn't
cause the problem and there's some
really
fascinating research here it's important
people to understand what did cause the
problem
so that we can help them understand how
to correct these metabolic illnesses
which are really at the root
of most chronic disease today and i
think it's an evolutionarily
inconsistent consumption of excess
linoleic acid
we can talk about that if you want but
hopefully that clarifies our people i
definitely think low carb is helpful for
a lot of people
but there are people can run into
hiccups with it i hear people say oh i'm
getting palpitations and i say we'll do
salt
and then if that doesn't help i should
just add some carbs in and they say oh i
feel much better
as long as they're not metabolically
disordered they can usually tolerate it
yeah i had palpitations for five months
but i was
couldn't eat any carbs so i just sucked
it up
i should have added an electrolyte that
was before i knew electrolytes i just
like i would have been helping
laid in bed and was like well you know
at least it's not arthritis but
but yeah um yes that's all good
information
okay well where can people find you paul
uh so probably the best place to find me
is at heart and soilsupplements.com
all of my podcasts are there all my
youtube videos are there we've got lots
of information there about
nose to tail carnivore diets and the
desiccated organ supplements
and through the website they can just
email me dr paul dr paul
at heart and soil supplements.com if
they have questions i'm happy to help
with that i like answering emails these
days
great great well thank you very much for
coming on that was fun
yeah my pleasure thanks for having me no
problem i'll talk to you soon
yup can't wait
you